Did you miss me?
You'll be hearing a lot of that today, I think.
You'll be hearing a lot of that today.
And my congested sniffle.
Don't die, please!
I'm already dead!
Mint-chan, I'm home!
Still coughing?
What do you mean, still?
I...
I basically just got sick.
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Oh, kind of big.
Hi, everybody!
I'm home.
I'm back.
Welcome.
Welcome back, master and mistress!
Thanks for the pink.
If we need to contact you for something, can we do it via ritual summons?
Or a Luigi board?
Preferably, not a Luigi board.
I mean, you would think that those are kind of great, but...
It's not so good.
Because a whole bunch of lines get crossed, you know?
Andricos, thanks for the tan gift, dude!
Welcome home, thank you!
Why not Luigi board?
Because, I just said, so many other ghosts are just like...
It's my turn to use the Luigi board.
So you won't probably get me.
You'll probably get someone else.
Some freak.
Oh my god.
They say it's me, they'll be like...
Um, hello.
I'm Mint Phantom.
Hello.
You're speaking to Mint.
How can I help you?
And you're like, wow.
The connection makes you sound really weird.
You're like, and the ghost is just like...
Ah, yeah.
I'm just a little shy.
Voice reveal.
I love you!
Thank you so much!
I'm glad I met you.
Thank you so much.
I love you the most in the world.
I love you!
Thank you!
I'm happy.
I finally met you.
I finally met you!
Are you saying we'll get Frogbert even better?
That guy, he's not dead?
What are you talking about?
That guy's not dead?
Anyway, we can talk with some...
What's the word?
Some...
Balloons BGM.
So, a couple things happened.
First, I went to Off-Kai.
I went to Off-Kai.
I didn't get to really talk about it.
Well, I talked about it in the podcast with Matara, if you listened to that.
Um...
But, uh...
That was a while ago now, I guess.
Right?
It was quite some time ago.
And, um...
Um...
Uh...
Off-Kai, my beloved.
Not mine.
Well, yes.
I had a great time.
But, uh...
I saw you got swarmed on a robot at Off-Kai.
I did!
I thought I was gonna be able to go around and, like, explore.
No!
I just...
I got carried...
To one...
I didn't even get to move myself.
I got picked up...
Like...
Like a baby.
I felt like I got picked up like a child.
And I was carried...
To...
One location.
And people lined up.
Um...
That was funny.
But thank you, Oshilive, for having that happen.
Um...
And, uh...
Oh my goodness.
What else happened?
Uh...
We did a panel.
It was a lot of fun.
Um...
And...
Matara and I said...
I mean...
As we...
And, um...
Gugu gaga, Baby Minto.
Gugu gaga.
And, um...
I mean, if you want probably better...
Better...
Um...
Stories...
You should probably go listen to the podcast episode.
Um...
The next podcast episode, we recorded...
I mean...
Yeah.
We recorded and that was good fun, because it's just the two of us being little sickies.
Sick hags.
The stream summary I got is Frogbert is no longer on the streaming platform and viewers are upset.
Okay, that guy... give that guy a break, okay?
He'll come back eventually.
Is that the one from the tiny room?
Oh my gosh.
I did talk about it in the last episode.
Kind of what happened with our hotel.
I guess I can be a little bit more specific now, because neither of us are staying there anymore.
I believe Matara is still in Japan, but she moved to a different hotel.
But oh my goodness.
The fake apartment hotel.
Oh, I was so... I don't think...
I would like Matara to describe the look on my face when we first stepped into that room.
And I was just like, huh?
Like, just pure... disappointment.
Well, shock and disappointment and confusion and everything.
Angry ghost.
Oh, I...
Oh my gosh.
You got ripped off?
No, no, no.
I mean... I think... I think what... Okay, so I know what had happened.
I searched.
I searched...
Apartment hotels in Japan.
Because those are totally a thing and I don't do Airbnb.
I already said this on the podcast, but I'm still so angry about it that I'll say it again.
And so...
But the hotel we stayed at...
You know what?
I'm just going to name it because I'm never going to stay there again.
Out of fear...
I'm just going to name it.
Because I'm never going to stay there again out of fear of booking the wrong hotel again.
And I'm...
And I do believe that it was Expedia's fault.
Because...
Hold on.
I'm going to Google it right now.
So it was called...
Monday...
Hotel...
Ho...
Monday...
Hotel...
Ap...
Apartment.
Now, I need to know where I messed up.
How...
Where did the mistake happen?
I hate Mondays.
Oh, my God.
It actually is so funny because I was just...
I literally was like, I hate Mondays.
Because...
Because of this.
So...
Okay.
This is also where the confusion happened.
Because I booked the premium version of the hotel.
See, I'm looking at the pictures right now and it says...
Oh, but it says apartment premium.
See, when you think a premium hotel, I was just like...
Oh, maybe that's what they call their larger size rooms, right?
Which, technically, they were kind of larger size than like a normal business hotel.
But, come on.
That...
That wording is so confusing.
And so...
I booked for the Monday premium hotel and not the Monday apartment premium hotel.
Which was literally right down the street.
Literally right down the...
Oh...
And there's some...
There are a bunch of these, actually.
Wow.
Actually, I didn't realize they were so...
Abundant in Tokyo, but...
That's just bad naming.
I know, right?
That's so frustrating.
And the worst part is...
Well, not the worst part.
I mean, it was still a very nice hotel.
But, if you are ever trying to get an apartment hotel...
Book for the apartment premium hotels.
Not the regular premium hotels.
Because...
Also, I only booked...
I booked very...
Not booked.
I packed very few clothes.
I was just like...
Oh, I'll just do laundry like every day.
Because we'll have a washer and dryer in our bedroom.
No worries.
So, I had like no clothes.
And I was having to go to the laundry like so much.
And it cost...
It's expensive.
It's 300 yen to wash your clothes.
And then...
100 yen for 30 minutes in the dryer.
It was so...
It was just...
I was miserable.
I was so miserable.
And then I was stuck in my little room with Madara.
The whole trip...
Was...
Fine.
I got to go out for two days.
And...
I bought some clothes.
So, I'm glad about that.
Because I did buy some clothes.
But I didn't get to get...
I didn't get to get all the clothes.
Like I was like...
Oh, I forgot to get these other things that I wanted.
I'll go back out tomorrow.
And then tomorrow is the day...
I basically was sitting in the hotel room.
And I was like...
Oof, my body feels heavy.
I wonder if this is delayed jet lag.
And then I like took a nap.
And then while I was napping...
I woke up...
Like at 9 p.m.
And I was like...
Uh-oh.
I have chills.
And I was like...
Uh-oh.
I don't think this is just my body being heavy anymore.
Ugh.
Did you get to visit any maid cafes or idol shows?
Yes!
Luckily.
The day after we arrived...
There was an idol show that I...
That we got to go to.
And...
So we went there.
That was good.
And...
Then the day after...
The day after...
We were actually supposed to go to...
Um...
A theme park.
We were going to go to Fuji-Q.
Uh...
With a couple people.
But because Matara was like...
I don't know, man.
I'm starting to not feel so good.
And I saw a lot of people saying that they got COVID at Ofukai.
But none of the people that we interacted with...
Got COVID.
So we were like...
Hmm...
But she was like...
I'm really not feeling well.
So I think I'm gonna...
I think I'm gonna test because...
I don't want to go out with you.
I don't want to go out with people.
And get them sick.
You know?
Like...
She was like...
Really worried about...
Um...
You know?
Because it was a few people...
A few other VTubers that we didn't know very well either.
And we were like...
She was like...
I don't know how...
You know?
How their bodies are.
I'm a roach.
I can survive.
But she was like...
I'm...
You know?
Concerned about the other people.
And so...
Um...
Fuji-Q...
He was like...
I can't go.
We couldn't go.
Because she tested.
And then...
It was...
Yeah.
She got COVID.
And then I was like...
Well, if you're sick...
I'm probably sick.
And then I tested.
Because...
One of the things that we were wanting to do...
Or...
Actually, the reason I went to Japan...
On this trip...
I was originally not going to go on this trip.
But the reason I went...
On this trip...
Was for one reason.
And...
We didn't get to do it.
Because...
And...
It was...
The Bishoujo staff was helping us...
Set it up.
And...
Basically, they were like...
Hey, you guys said you have COVID.
So...
We're going to have to cancel.
And I was like...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I feel fine.
Let me test.
If I can still...
If I'm fine...
Can I still do it?
And they were like...
And then I tested.
And I was negative.
And I was like...
I'm fine.
Because if I did the test right...
I...
I just posted.
Because I assumed...
And you know what...
Assuming makes the ass out of you or me.
So...
I was like...
Oh, no.
Please, let me go.
And I ended up getting sick afterall.
I could still fight.
That was literally me.
I was like...
No, no, no.
Wait, wait.
I was like...
I made a mistake.
Because in Japan...
They're still very serious about that kind of stuff.
So...
So, especially if you say, hi, I have COVID, they're just like, oh, cancel everything.
We will, we will.
Quarantine, quarantine.
So, we were like, okay, well, mint's fine.
Send her in.
And then the next day, I got sick.
What was the next?
Maybe the next day, day after.
I think it was the day after.
And I was like, oh, shoot.
So, we stayed in our hotel room the whole time.
Basically.
And, um, yeah.
I did go out.
The day before, I started feeling bad.
I did go to Akiba.
And Akiba, it was so weird.
It was really weird.
Like, the place was packed, first of all, because there was an Atlas festival that was going on.
And, uh, there was just so many people for that.
And, already, Akiba is pretty crowded because of, um, because of, uh, tourists.
So, um, it was crazy, crazy, crazy.
Let me see if I have...
I took, I posted, I think, the, um, I didn't take very many pictures because I didn't know how many pictures I could take.
Um, I think I, there was one...
Did I take a video?
I could hear, like, a concert going on inside.
No, I didn't take a video.
I only took, I only took the photos.
Um, but, uh, so that was crazy.
And then I was like, I wanted to go to, um, just a maid cafe to, like, chill.
Um, I was like, I'll go to a better, you know, not a better.
I was like, I'll go to, like, a, you know, a, a, a, uh, you know.
Stereotypical maid cafe in the upcoming days.
Today, I just wanna, I just wanna, like, chill.
I wanna, like, so I was like, I'll go to Cure Maid Cafe.
I'll go to Cure Maid Cafe.
There's a, a, a, like, an hour and a half, two hour wait.
And I was like, excuse me?
I have never, never, ever, ever had to get a reservation.
I was like, what?
That's crazy.
And so I put in a reservation.
And then I, um, I went downstairs.
And there was a Lucky Star Haruhi 20th Anniversary pop-up store.
So I was like, hanging out in there.
And I was like, yippee, this is cool.
And, um, you don't wanna chill in line for the maid cafe?
There wasn't a line.
It was, you put in a little, you, you apply for a reservation.
And then they call you back.
They were like, feel free to go anywhere and walk around.
So I did that.
My abode.
So.
I know, right?
I was like 20th.
And I was like, I think there's a misprint or something.
I meant to go back.
I was poor, innocent me thinking back.
I was like, I'm not going to buy much of anything because I'll just come back and get it another day.
So I didn't end up buying, there was like a cute little acrylic calendar that I was going to get.
So I didn't, I ended up not getting anything.
I'm so sad.
I didn't want to carry stuff around.
Um, little did she know, but, uh, and then I was like, well, I was like in the store for a while and I was like, man, it's still a lot of time before I have to go back to the maid cafe.
So I was walking around some more and I was like, you know what, um, let's see, you know, cure maid cafe had a really long wait.
Let's go check out, um, jam jam.
Jam is another really chill maid cafe.
And so I went there and I saw that they had a Kagura Nana, um, collab.
And I was like, oh my gosh, wait, this is so awesome.
And so I was like, I'll go here instead.
And so I canceled my reservation for cure.
And they were like, even though they were like, it's almost your time.
And I was like, no, I want to go to this one instead.
Um, and, uh, Nana Mama is so cute.
I know, I know everything was so cute, but I go in there.
And there's, they also, they're like, uh, you have to come back in an hour and a half.
Is that okay?
And I was like, okay.
I think, uh, I think the collab at the cure maid cafe was like date a live.
So I was like, I'd rather do Nana Mama.
Um, so even though I canceled, I was going to do Nana Mama anyway.
So I was like, okay.
I'll just wait.
Another hour and a half, I'll just do another hour and a half.
Wait, no worries, even though I had been waiting so much before.
And so I was like, you know what?
It's fine.
I'll go to, um, I'll go to culture zone, which is a big, like building of just a bunch of, a bunch of stuff.
There's like a bunch of floors.
The first floor was at, oh my gosh, it was absolutely insanity.
There was like.
There was just, there was like children, like on the floor, like playing with figures and stuff.
And I was like, what is going on?
Is this a Toys R Us?
Like, I went upstairs because there's an idol store in culture zone that I go to called trio.
And I go there, I go to the trio and it's gone.
And I was like, but, um, it actually, they moved floors.
I believe they, uh, I didn't actually get to go.
Because, um, I, uh, got distracted by some other stuff and I went into one store.
Okay.
This is why I said like, when we first arrived in Japan, Matara was just like, man, that whole trip, it felt, it felt like we're in the, we're in the twilight zone.
Like, and I was like, that's, I think that's the whole theme of this trip.
It just felt like the twilight zone.
Everything just felt a little off the entire time.
And I was like, what is going on?
What a curse trip.
It really was my flight back was so cursed.
Like the plane was having, luckily it was not a Boeing, but it was having, it was having tech issues and like the lights kept flashing on and on.
Like, you know how, like in the middle of a international flight, they'll turn the lights off so that you can sleep.
The lights would just randomly turn off in the middle of everybody.
So.
And then the music would start blaring because they were trying to fix the sounds.
We didn't even get to watch the safety video because they were having so many technical issues.
And like, sometimes the music would, they had like a radio that they would play and it would just start blaring music in the middle of the flight.
It was so cursed.
And, um, but yeah, I was in culture zone and I was in a random zone.
I was in a random store looking around because sometimes I like to just, um, there's like these stores that have cubes of figures and I like to see if I can find any metal gear stuff in there, but I was in a random store and some guy came up to me and he was like in English.
He asked me, are you looking for anything in particular?
I said, no, just looking, which that has never happened to me before.
I was like, huh?
Like I thought he was up, but I had never been in that store before.
Haunted plane, my bad, my bad, sorry, um, but, uh, you've got tourists, like that has never happened to people or someone came up and was just like, hey, are you looking for something?
It was very strange.
I was like, oh, no, I'm, I'm fine.
I'm just looking.
Thank you.
And I left because I was like, don't talk to me.
Even if you're, even if you're a store attendant, please don't talk to me.
And I went to the next next floor and, um, there was a Toho collab, which, um, of an artist, um, who's specified in Remilia-sama.
So I was just like, Ooh, yippee.
So I got some stuff there, but the guy also, there was a guy there who also started talking to me, but this time in Japanese, it was just like, Toho ga suki desu ka?
And I was just like, yeah, I love Toho.
And then, and then he started talking to me and asking me questions.
But this guy worked here, but I was like, Arigato, arigato.
Chuu.
Thank you.
Did our COVID cycle sync up?
Hazakashii.
Oh my gosh, hazakashii.
But, um, but I was like, huh?
Huh?
Why are you talking to me?
Why are you asking me questions?
But then the guy, the guy from the, from the previous store comes to me.
He walks into this store and he starts asking me questions again in English.
And I'm like, wait, you weren't a store attendant in the last one.
He was just some random guy asking if I was looking for something.
He wasn't even an employee.
I don't really even remember what he was asking me.
I was so shocked.
I was like, why are you here?
He works at both locations.
I was so confused.
I was like, I literally thought he was an employee of the previous store.
He's the building manager.
I think he was asking me like, um, uh, uh, if I like was studying or, you know, um, I don't know.
I don't know, just those kinds of like questions you ask foreigners.
I was reverse haunted by this guy.
I was like, so funny.
But it was so bizarre.
I've never been asked...
I've never been talked to in Akiba like that.
So I was like...
Maybe because there was such an influx of foreigners that day.
I don't know.
But...
I got some of the... I got some Touhou stuff.
So that was fun.
And then by the time...
By the time everything had finished, it had already been an hour and a half.
So I got the hell out of there before that guy could come back to the next...
He probably...
I was like, I wonder if he went to the next floor and was waiting for me there.
So I ran.
I was like, well this guy...
Surely doesn't have a...
A reservation for jam Akihabara.
So I ran away.
Oh, he just really wanted to practice his English.
See, usually like that's...
I don't find that ever to be the case with people.
Very rarely do people want to practice their English.
Oh my goodness.
But yeah.
So that was a very strange time.
I was...
I was like, what?
Akihabara is just strange today.
The whole...
I'm in the Twilight Zone!
I didn't...
It was just such a weird trip.
And then...
Like I said, I got sick.
So Mitara and I, we just...
Laid in bed...
For...
Four days and then I went home.
So...
Yeah.
I'm very sad that...
I do feel like it was a waste of a trip.
I feel...
Hold on, let me take a sippy.
I feel very like I...
Wasted a lot of money and time and everything going.
Which...
I mean, obviously we couldn't have known, but...
It just really...
Would you have stayed longer if you didn't get sick?
No, no.
I left...
I actually left a little bit early.
And a dot very early.
Like a...
Just a day early.
Because I was like...
There's no point in me staying here.
So I just...
Yeah...
It was...
It's...
I just...
I think I'm most disappointed...
Or not...
Well, not disappointed.
I'm most frustrated because...
In July I've...
Kind of really overbooked myself.
And so now I'm just like...
Having to...
Plan...
See, I was...
Planning on going to...
Like...
Maybe...
Go around Anime Expo a little bit.
Since I'm going for the...
Um...
For the virtual concert.
But...
I've decided that I'm just gonna go to the concert and then head back immediately.
Because...
Uh...
I've already...
Missed so much time streaming.
And...
Um...
And I'm also going to have to probably go back to Japan...
In July sometime.
So Matara and I are trying to figure that out too.
And it's like...
Uh...
It's uh...
Yeah...
I'm just really frustrated about it.
Hmm...
Yeah, yeah.
But oh well.
Hmm...
Oh well.
Don't worry about us if that's the case.
But I mean I do...
Not...
I'm...
I mean...
Wait...
Hold on.
I'm trying to think...
I worry...
About...
Like...
I mean...
It's just like that whole...
If I'm not making content, I'm not doing anything with my channel.
Man, man, man.
Um...
There was stuff that I did get to take care of while in Japan.
And hopefully some cool things that...
Happen.
Um...
Of things that I...
Was doing in Japan.
But I didn't have to be in Japan for those things.
Is the...
Is...
Is the thing.
Cause...
Matara was just like...
Look at all the stuff you got done!
And I was like...
I would've gotten that done in my maid cafe too!
What?
Ugh...
That's rough broski.
Why do you hate us?
No!
Um...
I was...
Rather saying...
It's...
Like...
I'm not like...
Oh...
I'm not worried...
About...
Like...
Why would you guys forget about me?
But I kinda worry...
About that.
Kinda.
Kinda worry about that.
According to YouTube...
You are frustrated at Anime Expo.
So frustrated.
But yeah.
Um...
Hmm...
Were you able to receive gifts from...
Mintos?
From who?
Me?
Are Oshis a little tsundere?
What do you mean by that?
You'd have to do a lot better than that...
To get rid of the worst of them.
Hmm...
Yeah...
You're stuck...
Good.
Where Mintos...
I can count nine of them right now.
Anyway...
Yeah...
So I really...
Wish I could say more about my trip...
But I...
Don't quite have so much about my trip.
You know.
Just kinda...
Well,
isn't that quite mysterious?
Let's see guys, let's see...
Let's see where do we want to go today?
I have to unlock some of these harder ones.
Rake!
Oh!
Oh, I can unlock it!
Wait, click to unlock.
Oh!
Be the beginner map.
Oh.
Haunted!
Looking forward to the concert during AX.
I tried to prepare the VIP tickets but they sold out so fast.
You girls are so popular, it's crazy.
Good luck!
Thank you!
Oh, thank you for reminding me.
Hold on, I have to respond to something.
Looks great!
So cute.
They were showing me the... some of the stuff for the T-shirts.
The Among Us 2 got ejected for being sus.
Someone went welcome to membership but then they disappeared.
Was it you, Kenny?
I started my Metal Gear experience with Phantom Pain.
Are you done dying from an aneurysm yet?
Because I lied, I started with the original on the NES.
I'm old as hell.
Younger than Mata, though.
She's so old.
It was Ken... no?
Huh, Kenny, huh?
All you ever got and nothing big happened in my life.
A dog I used to watch named Duck Duck was given up by his mother.
He and I now live together full time and watch you together...
Duck Duck!
That was a dog's name, Duck Duck.
So, Sophia, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you!
I've got an interview for MGS CON 2 staff in like 7 minutes.
Let's go, Road!
You're gonna staff?
Speaking of Metal Gear...
Oh my god!
I ordered the...
Dell, thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Freaky ghost, Sophia.
Metal Gear... let's do Haunted, even though it's a harder map.
We'll do it on Medium.
Oh, wait, hold on, you guys.
Hold on before we talk about Metal Gear.
Look, I have...
You can't see... there we go.
I have so much money, I can buy a hero.
I was trying the new hero.
Where is she?
Oh.
Rosalia, she's so cute!
So cute!
Doing subsistence for MGS 3?
I don't know yet.
I haven't decided.
We're gonna start Metal Gear next week, so...
Ironfall!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Did I say thank you Dell already?
Did I?
Thank you!
July!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Be my child!
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
Commencing Virtuous Mention.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
Oh my god, fight, sis!
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you, guys!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Welcome back, Minto.
Can I get a happy birthday?
As cursed as you want to sing it.
It was on June the 2nd.
Happy birthday, Warsaw!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
I had to do it fast, cause it's quite past your birthday.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh!
Why are there so many gifted?
Take up the...
Thank you for the 10!
Kyle!
Minto, fresh Kyle!
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Valentine!
Thank you for the 50!
Oh my gosh, BigAnanimate!
Thank you for the 5!
Okuro, thank you for the 5!
Mervy, thanks for the 10!
Oh my gosh, wait, you gave it to me for the 20!
Oh my gosh.
Gavel, thanks for the 5!
I can't keep up!
Wait, it's like...
Delayed, though!
It's like, delayed!
Stop!
So many gifted!
You'll get a sub!
It's too fast!
Stop!
I can't keep up!
Oh my god.
KZeropter, thanks for the 5!
Superliminal, thank you for the 20!
Detective Jones, welcome to my membership!
Thank you!
Joseph, thank you for the 20!
C2!
Thanks for the 10!
KBorn, thanks for the 10!
RockBerupper, thanks for the 10!
Rayback, thanks for the 5!
I cry when I fart!
Thanks for the 20!
And Draco, thanks for the 10!
Weepin, welcome back!
Wildestruck, thanks for the 5!
JR, welcome back!
KZeropter, thanks for the 5!
RockLeon, thanks for the 5!
I think I'm repeating people!
Nils, thank you for the 50!
Oh my gosh, you guys, please...
Kenny, thanks for the gifted!
Good playlist, thanks for the 10!
You guys are trying to talk!
Derpyster, thanks for the 5!
Joseph, welcome back!
You guys are trying to talk!
Should we buy a new hero, is what I'm trying to...
Ah, Stakiro!
Thanks for the hot koi soba!
Micmac, thanks for the 5!
Chidonchan, thanks for the 5!
InvisibleMoose, thanks for the 10!
Prince of Denmark, thanks for the 20!
Bloodlust, thanks for the 10!
Speak, then!
Stofan, thanks for the 10!
Should we get a new...
1?
Thank you
for the 50!
Lost at the store, thanks for the 10!
Kenny, thank you for the 1!
I saw it, I saw it before it disappeared!
Cody, thank you for the 10!
Which monkey is the Nacho Libre monkey?
I don't know...
I don't think he's in this movie.
Buy the coolest one?
No, because he thinks we're the 5!
Damn, over.
Which is the coolest one?
We have 5,000 monkey bucks.
We could literally...
Oh, I was going to say we could literally buy any of them, but we can't buy Geraldo or...
Covid virus.
Setsuna, thanks for the 10!
Citizen Phoenix, thanks for the 10!
Saora?
She seems pretty cool.
Kenpop camel.
Is she good?
I can't believe skins are so expensive too.
Oh.
Quincy.
Those scrolls lead to a quest for the heroes.
Yeah, but you don't get the heroes.
You just get rewards for them.
I'm drunk!
Thanks for the 10!
Saora is the best.
Saora can solo chumps.
Damn, really?
Fat, I mean...
Pat Fusty.
Checkraitor, thanks for the 20!
Classroom.
Just passed my interview to become a full-time cardiologist at a hospital.
Let's go, Ashwin!
Wow.
You're smart.
You're a doctor.
You're a real doctor.
So, should we get Saora?
She pretty good?
Yeah.
Kind of sad.
Maybe I should save up for the haunted man.
Look, it kind of looks like you a little bit.
Kind of looks like a wisp.
I'm gonna grab that tooth.
Let's go!
Corvus.
Going on a trip to New York in late August.
Can you recommend some places to see?
I'd love to see Federal Hall for MGS2.
I don't know many places in New York though.
Something I think of Ryan.
Thanks man.
You're pretty cool yourself.
What is something to do in New York?
Federal Hall.
I wanna go stand where Solidus died.
Catch me on the back of the statue.
There's like peace sign.
Oh my gosh, I wanna go see where the president died.
I don't plan on going to Anime MYC though.
I thought maybe to go for the Hololive concert but...
I think I'm too booked up in July and in August.
So it's kind of hard.
And now we're overlapping.
Oopsie.
Glad to have you back, Mint.
I'm so happy I got to say hi to you at Ofukai.
Yeah!
Catch Mint jumping on the random cargo ships off the Brooklyn Bridge.
Maya!
So happy to see you back, Mitochan!
I'm glad we could see each other at Ofukai!
I hope you're feeling okay.
But I didn't get sick at Ofukai.
I'm sorry, Tara.
It's not my fault.
It's not me!
TV table tray.
Thanks for the 10.
You're welcome.
Thank you so much.
I blame the roach.
As you should.
Should I get Saada because she's cool?
Actually, I really want this skin.
Maybe I'll get her and then save up for this.
Look how cool she looks.
Actually, I've been wanting this skin for a while.
I've been wanting this skin for a long time.
The Raiden skin kills me every time.
Jiangshi's skin is so good.
It really is.
It's really cute.
Saada is really good.
All in favor of buying Saada, say aye.
Thanks for the super chat, you guys!
Xbox Showcase showed MGS Delta outside my own freakout.
I was wondering...
Oh boy, I wonder how Mint is going to react.
I got the Collector's Edition and Backpack Ordered.
I got the...
I didn't get the...
Aye, aye, aye, aye, aye, aye.
Okay, that's a buy.
I didn't get the...
I got the...
My blade's legendary.
I didn't get the...
I got the other tactical backpack before they announced the camo one.
But I like mine more than the tactical one.
I like mine more than the tactical one.
Or the camo one, I mean.
My friend Leah's birthday is this weekend.
I want to surprise her with a happy birthday from you.
Would you sing her a ghostie happy birthday?
Thank you!
Bia, your friend Leah.
Leah!
Happy birthday!
I've been asked to sing a happy...
A ghostie.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Leah.
Happy birthday!
Okay, let's try.
Let's go to haunted.
Medium is premium.
What does this mean?
Oh, you can't see.
I can't see it because I'm a big head.
Hold on.
I'm going to scoot down a little bit.
What does... what does this mean?
I don't know.
I've never seen it before.
Are you guys still gifting?
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh.
Joseph, Duffy, I don't even know how many you gifted.
I'm just...
Say your name!
You have an upgrade.
Oh...
You can unlock their final form.
Oh, is that what that means?
Wait, like this?
Oh, no I can't.
No I can't.
Morning, dude.
Thanks for the 10.
Hi, Mint.
Hello.
Hello, Mr. Bush.
It's for a challenge.
Okay, okay.
Hmm...
Let's try her out.
I'm just going to put her...
Where should I put her?
Here.
Let's make some ribbons!
Some what?
Jamie!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Oh!
Oh shoot!
They come from this way too!
Uh oh.
She was almost on beat for a second.
Mr. Minto.
Mr. Minto!
Can you please say LOL, weep, and get rekt?
LOL, weep, and get rekt?
LOL,
weep, and get rekt?
I discovered you through Hanya.
You became one of my favorite streamers to watch.
Keep up the dope work, dude.
Thanks, DJ!
The other day, sometimes I'm like, yeah, I'm indie, but I can't, I want to like, I should behave better sometimes, you know, I, uh, I almost tweeted, I almost just tweeted Sarah's Fauna, just cause I really like her.
But I'm glad I didn't, because the other day she followed me back, and I was just sitting there going, ooooh, I was like, ooooh, I was so happy, but real though, right?
She's just so cute.
I just, I just kind of like her a normal amount.
Look at her go.
I'm saving up cause I want to buy this boat.
Real tweeted.
Uh oh, uh oh.
Everyone's going to say bad placement.
Normal amount.
Uh oh.
It's not showing me gifted.
Are these old ones, or?
It's not showing me.
It's just showing me people who are gifted.
Oh, and let me move myself somewhere else.
Where should I go?
I'm kind of just peeking out like a weirdo.
What
if I go here instead?
What if I'm upside down?
What if I...
Hmm...
There's no bloons up here.
Right?
Australian stream now.
Dang!
She goes so hard.
I'm gonna put another one.
Preemptive sub.
Detective Jones, thanks for the gift!
This is hush money.
Not to wish Weepin a happy birthday for the next 10 months.
Him suffering is really funny.
Oh!
Is this hush money to not weepin?
What's wrong with...
Hey Minto, can we get a tiny Minto in every corner?
Fine!
Thanks for the 10th gift!
Thank you!
Minto finally came to Australia!
Yippee!
Stinky!
I don't wanna be here next to you guys anymore.
This area smells!
Where should I go?
Woah!
I'll just be like a big body here.
I don't know what else to do.
Wait, I'm kinda crooked.
Is this crooked or not?
I feel crooked no matter what I'm at.
That was better.
Okay, I'll just stand here.
Don't touch me!
Don't, don't point fingers at me.
Don't poke me.
Don't.
You're not allowed.
Normal day of Minto in her front yard.
Wait, you can remove these!
That's me in the window.
Right there.
You know.
Just normal things.
Stop!
Stop pointing at me!
I'm stepping on the balloons.
Yeah.
With my high heels.
Poke the Minto!
Stop it!
I wonder where I should have put her instead.
Did you say hi?
Okay.
Even better!
Are we breaking cafe rules?
Yeah, actually.
Made cafe rules?
You're not supposed to touch the maze.
Full of jelly.
I actually am.
Whoa!
Thanks, Kinky!
Peels.
Yeah, I had so much jelly.
I had so many vitamin jellies.
Oh, I have a jelly right here!
Hold on.
Actually, I can barely taste it.
It's so sad.
I lost most of my taste, you guys.
I'm having like the full COVID experience.
It sucks.
Can I smell it?
Yeah, I can smell it.
I can taste it.
Cognac.
Grape jelly.
Oh, sorry.
Jelly grape.
It's funny because when we...
When Matara and I were eating out of place...
We went to Kula Sushi.
And...
She was like, God, the sushi here is so bad.
The sushi here sucks.
This just has no flavor.
This was before we knew.
She was just like...
Later on...
Even after she...
Even after she knew that she had COVID, she was just like...
All my food here has...
Usually, I never have...
Usually, I never have bad food experiences in Japan.
But this time, everything's been mid.
I'm like, girl, are you...
I was like, Matara, think for two seconds why that would be...
In our current situation.
Oh, man.
Mission successful.
Join the Diamond Dogs.
MGSCon volunteers now.
See you there.
Yeah.
Yay!
Congrats!
She's like, think for two seconds why you may not be smelling or tasting stuff well.
So silly.
Look, I've been working on my upgrades and stuff.
I'm kind of in the way, sorry.
But I will almost have enough to unlock this whole thing.
Whoa, what's this?
Whoa!
I don't know what just happened, but...
Nice.
Did she figure it out?
Yeah, eventually, you know.
My boy Darcy is always fighting with this Elizabeth chick and everybody thinks they hate each other.
But I can see sparks whenever he's with her.
Should I tell her to just confess to her?
What are you, Cupid over here?
If it goes south, they're gonna blame you, man.
Do you want that blood on your hands?
Someone say my name.
Welcome back, Minto.
Thank you!
Chill for Ice Monkey.
What if we did only Ice Monkey?
I don't have enough for Ice Monkey.
I have to save up for Ice Monkey.
I'm
gonna put an Ice Monkey in the corner.
Nobody puts baby in the corner.
I'm gonna put him right next to me.
Hey, Ice Monkey.
Look at him juggle.
Oh my god, the monkey's juggling above my head.
There goes my little bloons.
Useless monkey.
Oh my god, he has so much XP from doing nothing.
Is this focus?
I absolutely am.
I think we'll do this one as the heats.
And this one as the twin guns.
I love when he spins really fast.
When he juggles really fast.
It's so funny.
I clapped when I saw Ice Monkey.
They showed MGS Delta trailer.
I thought it was Ace Combat.
They showed the planes.
Hahaha.
I'm sorry.
That scene is so iconic though.
Had to have been Delta.
Oh yeah, Metal Gear.
It's so weird.
Because usually I wake up.
I wake up, right?
And I see news about idols or something.
But this time it was the complete opposite.
I woke up and I saw news about Metal Gear.
So...
It was kind of a...
Strange situation.
Where I'm like, wow.
It's like...
Very opposite.
Dang, she's slicing and dicing.
I like that she gets camo balloons too.
It's great.
But I'm so...
I'm so sad.
I got the deluxe edition.
Um...
Wait a second.
How are like...
They hitting balloons over here when they're faced this way?
Why are the...
Why is...
Why is there stuff flying around?
What is going on?
Did you get the terrarium?
No, I got...
I got the deluxe one.
Which was the one for the UK.
Oh, it tracks.
The darts are homing?
They are?
No way.
But yeah.
Since they released the collector's edition...
At like 4 AM, I was asleep.
I did not get it.
Unfortunately.
I'm so, so sad.
But I think they'll re-release more.
I just have to be vigilant.
For uh...
For whenever that comes out, you know?
But it was so unlucky.
So is the collection actually sold out?
For now, yeah.
But like I said, I think they'll...
I hope...
Hopefully that's not just copium.
But I truly think they'll release more.
You can click spacebar to do the next...
Oh my gosh!
You're right!
Wow!
I didn't know you could click spacebar to do the next round.
Thanks.
Hehehehe.
Just have all your friends ping you on Discord...
When they restock it.
I don't think...
Anyone...
Is uh...
Um...
I think you guys ping me more...
On Twitter than on...
Than my friends would ping me.
Hahaha.
I think you guys ping me more...
On Twitter than anyone else.
Let's see.
Let's...
I like getting this guy in.
I'm gonna put him over here.
And we'll start getting in...
This.
Cause I really like this one.
What's the second upgrade?
Oh.
Gains 10 attacks...
10% attack speed for 1% life.
Wasn't watching the stream but I got...
Gifted a notif...
Oh!
Notification of a gifted member!
Big thanks for...
Well thanks for dropping by!
Thanks for...
Trying to have to do that!
Thank you though!
Thank you!
How you... How you doing up there?
Ice monkey!
Can you give us a juggle?
Give us a little wave!
Yippee!
Ping me more!
I accidentally woke up my boyfriend...
Because you kept making me laugh out loud.
Tyro!
Oh my gosh!
Stop lolling!
Stop raffling on my jokes!
Stop lolling so much!
Lol lol lol!
Raffle raffle raffle!
Raffle raffle raffle raffle!
Uh oh!
Oh no!
I didn't mean to put him there!
Uh oh!
Oh no!
I didn't mean to put him there!
That was close!
Let's do it!
Why didn't they...
Why didn't they get those...
Those ones though?
I know... I...
Can they not get the...
Oh maybe they don't...
Maybe I didn't do the...
What's the words on them?
The camel...
Boop boop!
Hope you were able to receive my gift.
The...
Um...
A figure!
I'll have to check.
From Afkai!
They haven't...
They haven't sent the stuff yet.
They said that they'll let us know when they sent it.
From Afkai.
But they haven't shipped them to us yet.
Have I made a mistake?
What, like the game?
Blue Archive!
Yippee!
Oh no, I love Blue Archive.
I'm gonna plant a tree.
Oh wait, I'm gonna plant it right behind him.
Put it in your radius.
Oh!
But I was really bad about keeping up while I was gone.
That was the volume by the way guys.
Is it too loud?
Just let me know.
In fact, I'm gonna turn it down just a tad.
Handle it!
Oh!
I thought we almost lost.
Okay, there we go.
Hmm, louder.
Was that it?
Um...
Where should we...
Hmm...
I gotta maybe get rid of these trees.
For five hundred dollars!
Craziness.
Let's make some more money.
Oh yeah.
Let's do that too.
No jacket?
It was a limited jacket made by Alpha Industries for the collab.
Oh, no way!
Really?
That's awesome.
Five hundred dollar monkey bucks.
I love sniper monkey.
Me too!
Gift of ten!
Thank you, Peculiar!
Thank you so much!
Oh!
Okay, now we have lots of money.
Look at them carts!
We're doing a little bit of lawn maintenance in my maid cafe.
And good news, I got my Mintara Mondays goods and bad news.
My desk chair broke.
Sorry your Japan trip was a bust.
Hope you feel better soon.
Thank you!
I'm sorry.
Your...
chair broke though.
Okay, now we can do sniper monkey.
Because he can see everywhere.
I'm gonna line him up all here.
A line of sniper monkeys.
Oh, that's not a sniper monkey.
Well, it would be nice to get this guy.
Maybe I could put him like...
I wish I could put him at the end.
You know?
We'll put one sniper monkey there.
One sniper monkey there.
And you're gonna be our fast sniper monkey.
And you're gonna be our...
full metal sniper monkey.
Sniper monkey!
And we'll have Levi.
And even more sniper monkeys.
So many sniper monkeys.
Thought it would have been best on a corner.
Yeah, I didn't realize how this map worked.
But that's okay.
You know what?
I was gonna say live and learn.
But I'm dead.
So, I just don't learn.
I never learn.
What's this one?
I've leveled up to this one before.
Super fast monkey.
We are...
Actually, maybe I wanna...
Let's collect this and upgrade you.
There we go.
And you.
Perfect.
Big sub.
Is it a big ol' submarine?
This one?
Oh, wait.
I should add more subs then.
Shouldn't I?
Let's add more.
Let's add another little guy here.
Maybe I should do this one then.
I'll go this route.
But I can't...
Oh, I can almost unlock it!
I might be able to unlock it soon.
Yeti, welcome back.
Thank you!
Full sub squad.
Well, this guy is not a sub.
He's an alpha.
Moeb!
What's she say?
Oh my gosh.
I'm being covered!
By notifications.
I'm also stepping on the banks.
I take that, banks!
But yeah, how were you guys while I was gone?
What happened?
Did you...
Did you miss me?
What'd you do?
Did anything interesting happen?
Saw it as Korean, I think.
Oh, really?
Okay.
Hmm.
Trying to decide what I want to upgrade.
If I want to upgrade any sniper monkeys, or if I want to upgrade...
Let's do this one.
I do.
Oh my god, it's so full.
Look at these guys go.
They're so cute.
I graduated school!
Let's go!
I got a 3D printer.
What are you planning on doing with that?
Watched game trailers.
There's a lot of great games coming out.
I mean, with Delta and...
I mean, Metal Gear.
Metal Gear is Delta.
But Delta and the Indiana Jones game.
I can't wait for that too.
I'm so excited.
I believe my Ace Combat 7 save replayed the entire game.
You got this.
Wait, you finished it today?
Never mind.
You did got it.
All I did was sit in a room staring at the awl.
Metal Gear.
Also Metal Gear.
There's so much Metal Gear.
I got the vinyl records this morning.
I'm very excited about those.
Oh my goodness.
I can't wait to get into video game vinyls.
This is the perfect opportunity to start, baby.
So...
Oh, yippee!
Wall.
No, you said awl.
I started my internship while you were gone.
Wow.
Look at you.
You're being productive in society.
Oh, what's this?
What's this?
Wow!
My truck broke down.
I spent two days in a rest area in the mountains in the middle of nowhere.
Are you okay?
Got my associates...
Wait.
Associates.
Is that associates?
AA degree.
Is that associates right?
Congratulations!
I got a degree!
I did this run after I came back from off clay.
You're so fast.
Sounds like an I survived story.
For real, right?
Are you actually okay?
I'm fast!
Oh.
I forgot to collect my money.
Um...
But yeah.
Oh, let's see.
What should we upgrade this one to?
Oh, I can upgrade!
Oh, dang it.
No, just kidding.
I have 31.
Um...
You know what?
I am gonna try this one.
Go down.
But what's the point of getting these?
If it doesn't shoot while it's submerged, right?
Hmm...
Um...
But now that I'm back...
Uh...
Um...
Let's see.
Oh, nice!
I can unlock this one.
Which I have all...
Whoa!
The more bloons there are, the more damage it does.
Um...
That sounds pretty good for...
Oh, monkey-nomics!
I can finally unlock that!
Um...
Oh, gosh.
Now that I'm back...
I'll be honest.
There's been things that I've been trying to handle.
But...
Um...
Things have been kind of...
Hmm...
It's been not so...
I don't wanna say not so great.
Just a lot of things were like...
Things that I'm hoping will be done...
By a certain time.
And I don't think they will be.
So...
Um...
It's been a process.
I mean, this is...
What happens when you're indie, you know?
Um...
Uh...
It's been a learning process for sure.
I'll say that.
It's been a learning process.
Find a decent turntable in the 200...
300, 400 range.
I saw...
Um...
I saw an Audio-Technica one that I was looking at.
Would you recommend?
Hold on, let me see it.
If I still have it pulled up.
It was an Audio-Technica...
Um...
It was in purple.
I kinda liked it.
A lilac.
ATLP60XBT.
Maybe.
I like Audio-Technica in general.
So...
I figured maybe going with them would be a good choice, right?
Perhaps.
Maybe.
Those are a safe bet.
Hmm...
Let me guess...
A little overwhelming?
Well basically I was trying to like...
Get a...
Somewhat of a...
Merch launch...
Merch line up...
For my anniversary.
Um...
But one thing that I was like...
Most excited about...
The person that I...
Was working with.
They came back...
Just a couple days ago.
And they were like...
A lot of factories didn't want to work with us because of a certain thing.
Um...
So...
But I finally found a factory.
I'll get back to you in...
In 30 days.
And I was like...
30... 30 days?
Oh...
So...
Uh...
Yeah...
I dropped one K on a commission and my artist just...
Ghosted me?
No!
File a dispute with your bank!
If that happens...
What's this?
Oh!
We can make them raise up!
Wait...
So...
How is it popping balloons if it's submerged?
I'm confused.
Since you asked, I passed my exam yesterday.
Let's go!
Wait...
Can anybody help me with this one?
Oh!
Radiation!
Oh...
I say... I say...
Reduces ability cooldowns everywhere by 20%.
Not a whole deal.
Yay!
Maybe I shouldn't have upgraded these monkeys the exact same.
But it's fine.
I just realized my mistake.
But it's okay.
This one...
Come on!
There we go!
Whisp Sweatshop to produce merch soon.
No!
I'm just hoping that...
You know...
That...
You guys aren't gonna be disappointed by a lack of stuff.
Like you're just...
I hope that you guys won't be like...
Man, is Mint doing anything at all?
She hasn't put out this or that or this or that.
I'm just a little worried about it.
Audio Technic is a good brand.
That model you mentioned looks okay.
It's not crazy about the belt drive on it though.
What?
Will that like kill my...
Records?
My web!
Wow!
We're like killing it, aren't we?
Just you having fun is good enough for us?
I don't know...
I still want you guys to like...
You know, be like...
Oh!
Mint does such cool things.
It's just been a little slow.
That's all.
Relax if you need to.
No!
You can always offer pre-orders.
Yeah, I was thinking of that.
Well, I mean, they'd probably have to be pre-orders anyway.
But...
I kind of have to solidify...
What...
What I'm doing at all.
I have to solidify anything at this rate.
But you know...
I'm doing my best.
I want to get this one.
The Spirit of the Forest.
Don't jump to the worst conclusions.
What do you mean by that?
Look at this guy.
Look at this guy up here.
He's like...
He's so fast.
What else should I build?
Oh my gosh, thank you for that!
It appears we meet again, Mint Monkey.
Nice to see my boy hiding in the corner.
Clutching the game.
How much experience do you think he has?
4000!
By doing absolutely nothing.
What a champ.
What a champ my guy is.
Click on the sub upgrades again.
I have ever...
Oh!
I was going to say I have everything!
One million...
What is this?
Unfathomable range, power, and synergies with other monkey towers and heroes puts all bloons under assault.
Four...
Four hundred...
What is this?
I've never seen this before.
Nautic Siege Core.
What?
Thank you, Red.
Thanks for two months.
One million XP.
Hold on, I'm going to eat some of my...
Oh, I'm starting to feel a little bit dizzy.
Oh, hold on.
I don't get nausea.
My friend, when she got COVID, she said she was really nauseous.
I don't get nausea, but...
I get lightheaded a little bit.
Don't be afraid to ask your friends for help or advice.
Yeah.
Um...
I think for me, it's like...
There are things that I want to do, but I can't figure out a way how to get them made.
I might have to contact a place directly and get it custom.
But also it's me being like, I want to do something cool.
But...
My limitations...
Are low right now.
My limit...
Yeah, my limitations are...
Restrict...
I have limitations.
I'm here, but...
Oh Bro...
We are here for you.
Don't sweat it, there's a cherry standing around here.
Wow.
Go Moab!
Moab!
Hans elevate.
Hans elevate rules!
Hooray!
Run to take the money.
Oh, yeah.
100?
What do you mean by that?
Why is it so expensive?
I've never seen that much monkey money before, ever!
I told Darcy to confess to Elizabeth.
She rebuked the F out of him.
See, I told you.
I told you!
Dang, that was fast.
I got sick even before I went to Ofukai.
Oh my gosh, no!
Everybody feel better.
Belt drive won't damage your records.
Just try not to touch the record while it's spinning or you'll wear the belt out.
Ah, okay, okay.
Direct drive doesn't have that problem.
I see, I see, I see.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for all the superchats!
Thank you!
What flavor of block game would you play with Bessie Bird?
I don't know.
She and I should talk about it, now that I'm back.
I hope you're getting over the crud quickly.
I think I would say I'm honest.
I don't want to spend the recovery end.
I would say that I didn't feel so bad for a very long time.
Especially once I started taking medicine, I was like, Oh yeah!
Oh yeah, I feel so good!
Mostly it was my head hurting.
My head was like...
Oh, it was like so...
Oh!
It was so bad!
But now, I feel...
My head hasn't hurt at all.
Mental...
That's a word.
I see I want this guy real bad.
How do I...
What's the best way to make money, you guys?
What's the best way to make monkey bucks?
I don't want to take out a loan.
I don't want to be in debt to anybody.
Maybe I should build another bank.
Payments missed you.
I missed you guys!
Banks?
Okay, let's make a bank.
I'm gonna put it right...
Is it still in range of him?
I think so.
Maybe, technically.
See, this one I don't want to go because...
Wait.
Earned heaps of money each round.
What's a merchant man?
Hopes of monkeys trail.
Huh.
Which is the best path to go?
Rob a monkey bank.
Which is the best path, you think?
Sorry, MGS.
Because of you, I just beat MGS2 and loving it.
I'm a Steam achievements fan, though.
Getting big boss code name took years.
I'm sorry, Fizz.
It's not even something I'll do.
Reminds me of a silly anime girl on the internet quote.
No expectations.
Yeah!
Bottom path?
Seriously?
You like the bottom path?
But it halves your value.
We'll try it.
So it just collects in there?
Or something?
We're working on our aim.
Yeah, what's that supposed to mean?
What's that supposed to mean?
Something.
Yeah, that's what it means.
It means you have to pass the time, right?
How long do I need to deal with it?
Oh, I see.
And then I'll pass it.
If I get the secret, I can't get out.
If you try it out, it'll be better.
But I don't like what I'm doing.
I'm gonna make it better.
I'm not gonna practice.
What?
Those are just normal cats.
Right?
If you think about it.
Yo, we are like killing it right now.
Maybe I should take out a loan for real.
Marketplace.
Wow,
look at it go!
Sorry.
Let's do the more valuable.
ZOMG!
That was easy.
Duck sized cats.
That's like the same thing.
That's like the same exact thing.
Oh my gosh, wait I can almost get him.
So close.
I'm taking out a loan!
Just kidding.
I'm going to be able to summon two phoenixes.
I'm taking out a loan!
Yes!
Now they start...
Yes, they start growing!
They start growing!
Collect that money.
Look at it go!
How are the kitties?
They are so good!
I...
My roommate had to take Butaro to the vet.
Duck shaped cats.
No!
Then they are just ducks!
Thank you so much!
Turns out he has maybe acid reflux and that's why he throws up all the time.
So he has to... I had to change his diet entirely again.
I was like ordering food for him in Japan.
My stupid sensitive cat.
Okay, maybe I can get this one now.
I like how he just like...
Scary, scary, scary.
DDT, I don't know if we are still ready for.
Poor old man.
I know, my stinky cat.
My stinky cat.
He is such an old man.
Uh oh.
I'm as sharp as I get.
Should I try this?
I guess I tried it.
Maybe I should have invested in something else.
Oh well.
But yeah, other than that...
No!
I think I would have lost that anyway though.
I think I would have lost that anyway.
My cat throws up sometimes but now I know that happens when he overeats.
Yeah!
That could happen.
Sometimes my cat eats too fast.
Dang.
But hey!
Insta monkey!
Monkey!
Yippee!
The first money on an intermediate map.
Oh monkey...
Oh no.
Monkey's play.
That was a good one.
That was a good round everybody.
We can still do carve.
That one is spooky also.
Be the beginner map.
For the first time.
Oh we got to get...
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go to...
You know what?
Let's just keep going through these.
We'll do this one.
When I see a monkey I think of Johnny Bravo.
Throw the monkey with me.
Wait, how does this go?
They just go straight across?
Huh?
Do they go down?
Should I...
Where should I put her?
Here?
Resort mode is really easy for Sada.
Oh, it circles three times.
Wait, huh?
They loop around a few times.
Ah.
This is the easiest map in the game.
Don't worry.
Maybe I should have let it...
See how it went before I even...
Wait!
Can I play this map?
Can I put monkeys on these chairs?
Oh, in the square!
I'll put her there instead.
I'll put her there.
Oh, yes I can!
See?
That's where Ice Monkey will be.
Ice Monkey is going to be...
Is going to be...
Lounging.
Yeah, Ice Monkey will be lounging in the chair.
Ice Monkey is really good in this map.
Okay.
Ice Monkey is coming.
Yeah, for lounging.
Evin, what is that...
What, what is that...
What?
Are you okay?
That tickles.
Look at him.
Oh, he's lounging.
He's just chilling little guys.
We can have two ice monkeys on a date.
Yeah, but like... ice monkey is kind of selective.
He doesn't just go out with any ice monkey.
Sada looks like a private chef for ice monkey right now.
You know how they like sit in their little booths and stuff?
She looks like a private chef slicing and dicing.
She's doing hibachi table for ice monkey.
Ice monkey and fire monkey forbidden romance.
There is no fire monkey.
There's alchemist monkey.
Two ice monkeys is just getting crazy.
Some would say it's a waste of my monkey box, but um... they might be correct.
I know who I want on the other table.
Me.
It's me.
I'm lounging with ice monkey.
You guys can't stop me.
She blew my tower to lie defense.
She left you defenseless man.
Someone come into the stream and say, where's Mito?
Little does ice monkey know.
There's a poison in that drink.
It's a matter of time before he croaks.
Or... not croaks.
Before he...
Yes.
Let's see.
What else can I do here?
Is there any magical things going on?
Okay.
Any... Let's put a... Let's put a... Let's put a boat monkey.
I don't think it's the end, is it?
Wait, if I do that, you can totally...
Oh my gosh!
I'm just standing in the middle of the room!
I'm just standing here!
So awkward.
Okay, click the base of the parasol.
Oh!
Oh, that's so cute!
Okay, I'm gonna go back to my normal spot.
I feel uncomfortable.
There we go.
We'll put another ice monkey there.
Some may say that's a waste of my monkey books, but...
Ice monkey doesn't know MGS Lore, he just explained it to him.
Click the car.
Coconut tree.
Was that a coconut crab?
Oh my god!
Good thing I got out of here!
That thing was gonna eat me!
Oh my gosh!
I was about to get Amelia Earharted!
Thank god I got out of there!
No monkey!
But down here on these three, we're gonna put sniper monkeys.
Sniper monkeys!
Sniper monkey!
Where?
Right here.
Sniper... lounging sniper monkeys.
Everybody's on vacation today.
We can do each route with each monkey.
You here.
And you here.
Perfect!
It's a fabled beach episode.
Is that what happened to her?
That's what was the theory for a while, actually.
Was that she got coconut crabbed.
You just got coconut crabbed!
You're getting eaten alive!
Have you ever tried mortar monkeys?
Is that this one?
I'm not.
You know what?
Today's the day we mortar monkey.
Which sounds dangerously close to murder monkey.
Look, I like how each of them have a different hat on and everything.
So cute.
So how do I use this guy?
I'm gonna put him right in front of their salad.
I just set a target, right?
Target!
Kill monkey!
Kill ice monkey!
Third wheel.
I lost a bet to Cole at offcut?
Why?
What happened?
Picker blast...
Increase...
What's the best...
What's the best route for our...
For our murder monkey?
How could you, Minto?
Hold on, I gotta remember which monkey is going with which direction.
Speed?
2?
0, 5, 2?
I guess I should actually put him to work then.
We'll just put him right there.
Dear Christ!
Look at the membership, thank you!
We were going to get lunch and I bet on one superchat that the people behind us would go to Curry Hyuga and then they didn't.
I had that one day at the convention.
It was pick up.
Someone picked it up.
I think someone from staff picked it up for me.
So what did you have to do?
You lost the bet?
What do you do now?
It was pretty good.
I actually didn't get to finish it though.
Basically, I took it back to my room.
I took it back to my room because we got it while we were signing the postcards for the Patreon.
And I forgot a spoon.
And I just never went back for a spoon.
So...
You know, it's kind of hard to eat curry without a spoon.
Oh, I had to give you money.
Yippee!
Appreciate it.
0-2-5 is probably the best route.
Oh, is it?
Okay.
Well, we're still early gathering, you know, so...
I lost a bet once.
My name was never the same.
Yeah, your name changes all the time.
Well,
don't eat curry with a fork.
What do you eat?
Sure.
Well...
No, not typically.
I usually use it with a spoon.
But I didn't have anything.
I didn't even have chopsticks.
I didn't have a fork.
I didn't have a spoon.
I had my hands.
And that's a little...
Like, that was a little...
I don't think... That was a little...
New fan who got interested in you thanks to all the cool Off-Kai merch and cosplay.
No way!
Saw your what order you should play MGS Short.
And I have to say, I started with MGS...
The Phantom Pain!
Oh!
Yeah!
I guess I'll just pass away.
I'll pass away again, I suppose.
Welcome back, Mii!
Thank you!
And there's a pocket utensil for Maria.
Oh, you're so right.
Because that also kept happening at the hotel in Japan.
Basically, we had a 7-Eleven by our hotel.
And it was like... I would ask them to heat stuff up for me.
And they're like, no, it's self-serve.
So I was like...
And so I would be like, oh, well, I'll just use the microwave...
Wait, I was like, I'll just use the microwave at the hotel.
But then I would forget because the forks and the chopsticks and all that fun stuff was all next to the microwave at the 7-Eleven.
So I would forget it.
I maybe should get an actual, like...
Travel spoon set.
Wait, they wouldn't eat your food?
No!
They told me to go use the self-serve... thing.
Burny stuff.
Woah, they're all on fire!
Nice.
Yeah, it's actually so messed up.
Pockety utensil.
Are you okay?
I've never been okay.
It was so sad for me.
You guys don't understand.
Started my Metal Gear journey with the NES port of the first game.
Bounced off of it because I was a silly kid who thought it'd be like Contra.
Understandable, though, I guess.
I suppose, you know.
I get it.
Oh!
Moeb!
Nice!
Gosh, we're so good at this game.
I've been working on setting up what's called an uncapping tube.
Save more wax...
Oh my gosh, for candles.
You and your candles.
So that's why Makise Kurisu wanted her own party.
I started with survive.
Base.
Ha ha ha.
Based.
Everybody knows you should start with Metal Gear Survive.
I'm gonna put Gatlin...
um...
Gunner...
We're gonna put him down here and we're gonna do our ray of doom.
Like so.
There we go.
Looing...
What do you think of people whose first Metal Gear solo was acid?
I don't really have an opinion, I'd say.
I think that's an interesting choice.
I think mostly, the reason why... I understand why so many people have started with 5.
The reason why I'm just like, don't do it.
Don't start with 5.
Is because you just don't understand what's going on, you know?
You're going to be so confused.
Okay, good.
Now we can use... I'll just do this.
We'll just get night vision for all of them.
The NVGs.
I'll start with 2.
See, even that's so confusing.
It kind of reminds me of how I started... My first Final Fantasy was Final Fantasy X-2.
Not Final Fantasy X.
Oh no.
No, I had to go in with the X-2.
And guess what?
I was so confused.
You'll be confused no matter where you start.
I suppose that's kind of true too, though.
You're not completely wrong there.
Why don't they juggle at the same time?
These stupid...
Stupid monkeys.
What can I do for you?
The idle one.
Yeah, I kind of loved it though.
It's what my friend gifted me for my birthday.
So I was like...
Yeah, I'm going to play that one.
So...
But I...
Did you at least play X after that?
Eventually.
Would you be surprised if I told you a lot of people start with Revengeance and end up very confused?
See, even though I started with Revengeance, I wouldn't say that I was super confused.
Wait, what does this do?
Oh, it drops a crate full of cats.
Oh, there it is.
I wouldn't say... I mean, I was confused, but I was like...
I...
I think Revengeance, as a starting point, is less confusing than starting at 5.
I also started Metal Gear as a kid with the NES game.
Not the NES.
I have fond memories of playing Pretend with my brother and our next-door friends.
We'd sneak around and our house is like Snake.
Aw, you were normal.
I played Pretend as Blue Eyes White Dragon.
I was like, yeah, I'm Blue Eyes White Dragon.
I'm just a dragon.
Why couldn't I play Pretend?
Why didn't I pretend to be Yu-Gi-Oh?
Why didn't I pretend to be like a human character?
I have no idea.
Instead, I was like, I'm Blue Eyes White Dragon.
It's better that way.
And then sometimes we would be the Harpy sisters or something like that.
Me and my friends.
I was going through my little brain.
Look, our little murder monkey is getting good.
He's getting all this XP.
Oh, it shatters the things!
Nice.
And then... I can't get this one.
Even faster reload.
Okay, we can almost get it though.
Maybe now?
No.
But several people gifted a... There was like a Yu-Gi-Oh...
What's the word?
A Yu-Gi-Oh Sanrio collab with McDonald's.
That is like the... Okay, that is... Now that I think about it, that is like so convoluted.
But some people gifted me at Off-Kai.
They gifted me the Cinnamoroll Blue Eyes White Dragon.
Which is just the most absolute perfect thing for me ever in the world.
But you guys, I feel like Kaushi Henning recently.
Have you guys seen the Hanamaru Obake Sanrio character?
Recently, I've been really obsessed with him.
We need a game where you play as Senator Armstrong.
What do you do?
You sign bills?
It's actually like a senator simulator.
Yu-Gi-Oh Sanrio McDonald's.
Yeah, it's all three together.
It's just... It feels a little much, right?
Maybe.
Yippee!
Free play.
Destined to be a Dragon VTuber fighting fate to be a ghost maid instead.
I've thought about, like, if I were to, you know...
If I were...
How do I say?
Able to change my image, you know, because...
I mean...
I... I was dead...
Several years ago.
Um...
Two!
But I don't think there would be much that I would change...
If I had the option to.
Wait.
Oh my goodness!
All the Donuts are so backed up!
Glad you're back!
Thanks Joshua!
Want to help me select the next movie I watch based on the title again.
Wait, isn't Steam...
Steam Boy is an anime, isn't it?
Dual Blood Rain.
No.
Hahaha.
Become a dragon.
I don't think I would want to be a dragon.
I don't think so.
I think there's a lot of Dragon VTubers.
But now there's also, like, a lot of Ghost VTubers.
When I...
When I first came around, there weren't so many, I think.
But now there's so many, I feel.
So many...
Actually, I should probably put in a...
This guy.
So he slows him down, right?
And then when this guy booms him up...
There are a lot of VTubers.
Yeah, I guess that's true too.
There definitely are a lot of VTubers.
Everybody rebrands to dragons.
Hi Hana!
I think dragons are just cool.
So I understand, you know, if people...
You know...
If somebody wants to be a dragon.
And maids.
Yeah!
There's a lot of maids now too.
But maids are...
You know, maids are a staple, so...
That...
That I can't be upset about.
They all died.
I'm dead.
Too.
But, you know.
I guess it is what it is.
It is...
What it is.
A snake.
I've seen like Lami VTubers before.
It's so cool.
Pshom!
I wanna get to the Ray of Doom, but it's so expensive.
What else can we...
Let's aim for...
This...
This one next.
Oh, let's get some more money too.
Money!
Lami!
There we go.
So now it's making its own...
Now I don't...
Yeah, it's just generating its own cash, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go.
Okay!
Come here.
Let's something that I think sweet.
Yeah.
Psh!
Oh!
So cool!
I don't...
Man...!
Let's go down there.
Okay.
Oh, in 30 seconds.
Is this really cool or not?
No, this is a good game.
It's so cool.
I learned something new...
And that was the end of it.
So...
A pirate warlord.
Oh, that sounds fun.
A bear.
There's plenty of bears, I think.
A detective.
And I'm not asking this to get ideas or anything.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not gonna be like, So my next outfit should be a bear.
A witch with a big hat.
There's always more necessity for big hats.
I'm gonna put in a... wait.
Oh, we're so close!
How do I get the money from here?
It just generates on its own, I guess.
There we go.
Kaiju VTuber.
My model is a sea angel.
Like a blonde fairy.
You have bad taste.
An alien.
I've seen those before.
What if it became an F-4 Phantom?
I bet you can't name 100 VTubers.
VTuber 1, VTuber 2, VTuber 3, VTuber 4, VTuber 5, VTuber 6, VTuber 7, VTuber 8, VTuber 9, VTuber 10.
100.
Hydra VTuber with different personalities for each head.
That would be insane.
That sounds so fun.
Actually.
I guess that's what's so great about VTubers.
You can have so much...
So many different kinds of creatures and critters and everything.
A scuba diver.
Do you want them to do actual scuba diving?
Actual scuba diving streams?
That would be awesome.
I would love to do a scuba diving stream.
Thank you.
Thank you money.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
I was about to click on Ice Monkey.
32, 14.
Okay, we can almost...
Maybe soon.
There we go.
Nice.
Curling you with a ghost tractor.
You can try.
Why are you guys always trying to destroy me, huh?
I say some stuff sometimes and you guys will not.
You can try.
Why are you guys always trying to destroy me, huh?
I can't get my hands on you.
What's wrong with you?
Date the Diver VTuber.
Metal Slime VTuber.
I diagnose you with goofy.
Thanks for the pink cubic!
I'd be a living rocket with a look like classic animation.
Butch Hartman, hips for sure.
Butch Hartman is the guy that does the art for Fairly Oddparents, right?
Does he have hips?
Like... does he have hips?
Jar VTuber.
What's wrong with you?
Stop it!
Kamen Rider.
Yeah, someone said Tokusatsu earlier.
I find it hard to believe that there's... I mean, there's definitely a Tokusatsu VTuber out there.
I actually feel like I could name 100 VTubers.
That sounds like very easy, actually.
Naming 100.
He makes women with hips.
Wow.
Fight me!
Voice crack!
Do it then.
If you can name Hololive, it's like 70 already.
That's what I'm saying!
I feel like 100 is...
Like, people are just like, do it then!
Bet you can't.
But it's actually like...
100 doesn't... 100 is not even that much, right?
You might need more monkeys.
I need a vacation.
I'm gonna put in Super Monkey.
No.
Just kidding.
I'm gonna put in...
Hmm.
Name a monkey!
We need more ice monkeys.
More monkeys!
You have all of chat!
Wow.
Why is my drum set so wet?
This angel is a type of deep sea slug.
They're cute.
Oh!
Cute!
I need another ice... 0-0-0 ice monkey in the... near the table.
Oh!
The Butler monkey!
Butler ice monkey.
He's...
Actually, this is ice monkey over here.
Who catches...
This is Ice Monkey catching his ice monkey.
Cheating on him.
Oh my god...
This is the ice monkey who's just like, OMG!
That's my lover over there!
We are in that seat, holding hands with that other ice monkey.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, scandalous.
Drama!
Absolute drama.
Let's put...
Air carrier.
Aircraft carrier.
Monkey.
Deploy the mini-planes!
Super Monkey is a hero.
Are you a hero?
Were you... Have you been...
Have you been a hero recently?
When's the last time you were a hero?
I offered a seat to an old lady.
I'm a hero.
I didn't expect money out of it either.
Though it would have been nice.
It would have been cool if she had been like Here's ten thou... Not ten thousand.
Here's a thousand yen.
That would have been so grand.
Oh my god, she's so crazy.
Sometimes they do that though.
Sometimes...
I was told once before that sometimes if you offer a seat to a grandma on a train, sometimes they'll give you money.
And ever since then, I've never expected it, but I'm kind of just like What if it happens to me one day?
I mean...
What if it happens to me one day?
I'm just saying.
Yippee!
Are you Himmel?
Himmel the hero would never hold the seat expecting for a thousand yen, but would be grateful if he got the thousand yen.
Nice of you to offer a seat to Batara.
It was so funny.
When I was on the plane back, I was just like I was like, I didn't get the... I didn't get the...
the rest of the clothes that I wanted to get.
And so I was like frantically trying to order them.
On the flight as it was taking off.
Look at this!
He covers the entire map!
He's so awesome!
What a great What a great passive.
So good.
Wait.
What can you upgrade?
Carrier flagship!
Okay.
That's not so bad.
We can upgrade that soon.
Prepaying a forward for that hero who gives up his seat for Mint Bachan.
There was a time when Mintar...
When Mintara and I I just literally said Mintara.
So funny.
Oh!
Those were DDTs?
When she and I were sitting and...
But we were separated and then somebody gave up their seat so we could sit next to each other.
But that's like different, right?
They didn't think... Oh my god!
He covers the entire thing!
That's so crazy!
That's like different though.
Oh, I should probably start.
Let's also get this bottom pathway.
Twin guns.
Long distance.
Okay.
Mintara.
It's because of the Mintara Mondays.
Oh!
I got rid of it.
Age of the Carrier.
Carrier flagship.
Oh!
This is round 93!
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
We went through 93 so easy!
We might actually get past 100.
Nice!
Oh, we shall see.
Trying to get...
Um...
Let's see.
Maybe I'll...
Maybe I'll get this guy too.
Yeah, let's do it.
Dun dun dun!
Dun dun!
Hey!
How's it go...
Oh!
How much...
We have like no experience on this guy.
That's okay though.
Seeing a huge lack of farming.
Chill out!
We're getting there!
Gosh!
Wasn't this one really expensive?
Yeah...
Maybe...
Hmm...
I'm trying to save up for this one.
Maybe we should just...
Moeb!
Let's die!
Drop!
Little late for farming now.
What are you talking about?
It's never too late!
It's only round 96!
What are you talking about?
We're going to...
We're gone, baby!
We're going, going, gone, baby!
Oh, I keep forgetting to upgrade this guy.
My bad.
Oh!
I don't even have time to click the thing.
Your farming is at 43.5% efficiency.
Your farming is at 43 .5 % efficiency.
VTuber, why do you not farm?
Because, um...
You know...
I like doing things natural.
Oh, natural, baby!
Okay.
I do...
Supply, drop, upgrade.
Oh!
Oh, I didn't even need it!
Oh my gosh, I didn't even need her!
99, baby!
I can't upgrade too much.
I think we're good.
Wow!
Oh, I thought... I said...
Oh, does this thing need to be close to her?
Uh-oh.
Attack!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Are you aware of the carrier's abilities?
No.
Let's see.
Does extra damage can place other monkeys on the upper deck?
Of the ship and increase attack speed of all...
Wait a second!
Oh my god!
I can put little monkeys up here!
That's wild!
That's so crazy!
This map is so easy though.
Because they loop so many times.
What should we put up there?
I'm gonna put a helicopter.
I'm gonna put...
I should put...
I feel like I should at least have...
A helicopter out here though.
Right?
Like...
I can't believe as many times as I've used the helicopter...
I don't have everything unlocked.
Put ice monkeys on top.
For decorative ice monkeys?
Oh, an alchemist.
Okay, we'll put one decorative monkey...
And one alchemist.
Oh wait.
Maybe I should have switched those.
Does he...
Will he reach all three of these guys?
Hmm...
How many monkeys do you think I can squish up here?
Apache is OP.
Yeah, I wanted...
I've been...
I actually...
I didn't realize I could actually unlock it now.
So we'll...
Do that.
Okay, hold on.
Let me get my...
Let me get my helicopter, guys.
Let me get my helicopter first.
Okay.
Go.
That was it?
No way.
That was so short.
Wrong monkey.
What are you talking about?
Oh, the wizard.
Wait, no.
Alchemist monkey.
Right here.
Is that MM on the carrier or EE?
That's EE!
Simba!
But wait.
If I put alchemist monkey here, will he reach all three of them?
Here, he'll only reach two of them, right?
Wait, does he have...
What's his...
Larger...
Oh, larger area!
It doesn't even matter where I put him.
Maybe I should put him here or here then.
Because he'll reach over here as well then.
Okay, we're gonna put him on the bottom.
Like that.
Wait, what's his radius?
Oh.
What happened to the larger radius?
You know what?
It's fine.
Who cares about the details, I guess?
Dang, I thought I would have enough money.
Come on, guys!
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
It was larger potion, not radius.
Um...
Will that acid pool do anything if I already have this on the ground?
I'll just put a second one.
It's fine, you guys.
There we go.
They're buddies.
Screw the ice monkeys.
We already have two of them over there.
Alchemist yaoi.
You said it, not me.
Those were your words.
I chose to read them aloud.
But those were your words.
Just stop at fast throwing.
Yeah...
I think it would be better to throw faster, too.
Okay, we'll just stop it then.
We don't have to do all the upgrades, I suppose.
Um...
32...
Where was...
Oh, no.
There was another one that I was gonna upgrade.
I know I need to do that one, too.
Huh...
Can't remember.
Hmm...
Hello.
Myoshi's a gamer.
Yeah, basically.
These poor monkeys, it's like...
Look, this factory is literally cutting into his bed.
This kind of sucks for him.
So sorry for you.
Let's get in Super Monkey, too.
And we'll get him buffed as well.
Which is the best route for the Super Monkey?
Because I started on both of these.
I think I was going for the Sun one, and then I was like...
I'm gonna go for a Robo Monkey.
Good to see you back home again.
I hope you have a great stream.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
The gamer monkey.
Oh, that was so fast.
I think we'll do the Crippled Moab.
Oh wait, I was gonna go for this one.
There it is.
Welcome back, Minto.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Next round.
107.
Money, money.
Top of a Batman is fun.
Power of the Sun is unstoppable.
Okay, then I'll save up for it.
I'll save up for it.
This one.
Holy moly!
Wait, how much is...
Five hundred thousand!
I think I need more trees.
I think I'm slacking a little bit.
I just realized
I could taste my coffee.
Yippee!
Whee!
It's weird the things that I can taste and the things I can't taste.
Because I can taste salt...
And...
I can taste...
I can taste the grape jelly.
Maybe my taste is coming back more than I thought it would be.
More than I thought it has.
Your health is going up!
Going up, baby!
No monkey village.
Where should I put it, though?
Where do I even need to put it?
Oh my gosh, I forgot this ice monkey was here.
Wait!
This guy is killing bloons!
We can't have an ice monkey that is doing something.
We have to have only useless ice monkeys.
I first realized the location of that guy, he was killing things!
He was helping out!
Degads.
Dang.
He pushes it back so well.
It's crazy.
Holy moly!
We have...
Have you guys seen how many lives?
We have 516 extra lives.
What?
Salt tastes as tongue versus a lot of what we normally taste in food is from the smell.
Well, I can actually smell.
I never...
I could actually at some point smell better than I could taste.
He was carrying.
We're gonna lose now.
We're gonna lose!
Okay, all my... these guys down here, max.
Very good.
514 extra lives.
How is that possible?
He just wanted to help.
No, ice monkeys are not allowed to help.
They're only allowed to be little cute goofy guys that juggle.
Okay?
We'll have to understand.
They're sensitive.
Maybe I should do...
Which would be the good one?
Epic range, maybe?
Simba!
Thank you for the...
Gifted!
Thank you so much!
Twin ice monkeys.
Ice monkey deserves to be pampered.
Exactly, exactly, exactly.
This is... I... I don't... I don't...
I know people will say that this is...
My... my map is not optimized.
But this is peak monkey optimization right here, actually.
This is what they don't want... don't tell you.
Third ice monkey.
Ice monkeys clap when they attack, though.
Aw, that's pretty cute.
My YouTube is breaking.
Dang.
You know what?
Maybe...
Hold on.
This is just long range.
This is... you know what?
Since I'm saving up, I'm just gonna go like this.
The DDTs always freak me out.
I don't... actually, this might be my longest game I've ever done ever, you guys.
This might be the longest I've ever gone in a game.
I think.
Do I sound congestion?
Do him so...
Yeah.
Oh, do a village right here so he can hit all types.
So true.
In fact, I'm gonna do it right in between.
It's even gonna get ice monkey.
There we go.
Only a little bit.
That's good, I guess.
Is it because I usually sound nasally?
Are you saying I usually sound nasally?
Fortified DDTs might be the end of you.
Hey.
Shun the non-believers.
I thought that was the end of me.
I need more experience.
He earns heaps of money.
I need heaps of money.
I need it.
Oh.
Just kidding.
This is...
I'm a ghost.
This is not a spooky number.
This is the spookiest number.
Number of lives.
Oh, my God.
It's this thing again.
Oh my God.
There's two of them.
Wait a second.
Uh-oh.
Am I in trouble?
Oh, there's three...
Oh, there's three of them!
Am I in trouble?
Maybe not.
Maybe I'm OK.
Get it off the screen.
It's haunted.
It's gone now.
You're all safe.
The forbidden number.
You're all safe here.
I protected you.
I'm your savior.
I wanna get to the 60,000.
Or what else can we buy?
Almost everything's maxed.
It's crazy.
What level is she at?
She's maxed too?
Everybody's...
So many people are maxed.
We're gonna reach 60k in no time with this.
120!
Holy cow, you guys.
This might be the furthest I've ever gotten, ever.
Looks like it's fanning my butt.
I think this is the furthest top!
Look at the membership!
What else should I add to the playing field?
What's another monkey?
Everybody name a monkey.
Name a monkey.
I wish I could upgrade to the Sun Temple, but it says it sacrifices someone, right?
What am I sacrificing?
Yippee!
So close.
For the Super Storm.
Oh!
Super Storm!
I wanna see what happens.
What does it do?
Storm blasts all bloon types for massive damage.
Blows them away from the exit.
Let's go.
Ice monkey!
Ninja monkey.
Could add a ninja monkey.
Why not?
Get a ninja monkey in there.
Guys, I didn't even, like, get past our... the front.
Oh my gosh.
Upgrade!
Ice!
I don't think I will.
I don't think I will, no.
Plays more karaoke stuff like break stuff when you better.
Okay.
Nah, I've said it before.
While I wouldn't mind...
I'm actually gonna put a gatling monkey on this end, too.
And this guy will face... this way.
Exactly like that.
And then we'll go... we'll upgrade his laser.
And then eventually we can upgrade this guy.
But I don't think I will, anyway.
Anna, are you the same person... wait, can someone check?
Was Anna the ice monkey person before, too?
Anna, are you... are you the same Anna of ice monkey fame?
I wanna... actually, not fame.
Infamy?
Why aren't you upgrading the monkey on the right?
Because we're gonna get to him.
We need 80,000.
I upgraded him first, and now we're gonna upgrade him.
Don't worry about it.
Hold on.
If YouTube wasn't so slow...
Oh my gosh.
Uh-oh.
YouTube is so slow.
YouTube is the worst ever, please!
Hold on, I have to restart my YouTube.
Ba-bam, ba-dum, ba-dum.
Dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun.
Okay,
there we go.
YouTube RAM usage is really bad, for real.
I know, right?
Okay.
Okay, we're getting to 80,000 you guys and then we'll upgrade.
Don't worry, it's gonna happen.
I believe, I believe, I believe.
And then we can upgrade that one.
Can you downgrade IceMonkeyStreamer?
IceMonkey is already 0, 0, 0 everybody.
That is the most... it's the least I can do.
This game is no monkey business.
This game is actually only monkey business.
This game is all monkey business.
This game can't be anything but monkey business.
This game is a business.
I'm losing stock right now.
They said if you don't upgrade Lazer, my stocks are crashing.
The monkey market is going to be in shambles.
Please.
You don't understand.
The monkey market right now depends on it.
Sell him to downgrade.
I like how...
I was gonna say, Sato doesn't even talk anymore.
DDT, handle it.
I miss him.
The monkey recession.
Upgrade this maid.
Am I not already...
Am I not already peak?
She is not peak, your honor.
What if your next outfit was an ice monkey maid?
I think that's a waste of money.
That is a waste of my money.
Look how much he is doing.
He is blowing these guys back.
He is blowing them.
He is blowing them hard.
Sounds like an investment to me.
Would then I be peak?
Would then I be peak if I were ice monkey?
And then I could sit there and juggle?
That would be the whole stream.
I would just sit in a little lawn chair and I would juggle sometimes.
I wouldn't even juggle all the time.
I would only juggle sometimes.
Holy moly.
These guys are fast.
Fast.
Okay, see we already have 50 out of 80.
52 out of 80.
I'm nervous.
Okay.
There we go.
It was just 11,000.
We could take the risk.
Maybe I should build another farm.
I wish I could upgrade these ones.
What's this one?
Whoa.
I know I wasted money, but it was worth it, okay?
What if you arrange that letter to spell out big M?
They hit absolutely nothing.
They just go...
Never hitting 80...
Shush, shush, shush.
We are hitting 80k.
Don't worry about it.
Let's do it.
Monkey call the arms.
Monkey arms.
What are those ice monkeys doing?
Yeah, they're just lounging.
They're hanging out.
And they're juggling sometimes.
Oh.
Hold on.
They'll definitely juggle next time.
Look at them go.
You have to be really fast though.
They scratch their butt a little bit.
They're peak monkey farm.
And you guys...
These guys are lounging down here as well.
Everybody, this is just the most relaxing game ever.
Actually, I'm quite impressed at how far we've gotten.
I'm actually super duper impressed right now.
I'm like, damn.
Maybe I'm good at this game.
You know?
I can upgrade this one though.
You got...
No.
I'm gonna get to 80.
We're almost to 60.
What are we saving for?
This guy right here.
He's 80,000.
Ray of Doom.
He's expensive.
Damn.
She's good.
I thought of that.
I mean, do you guys know that?
Do you guys know that camp rock clip where the girl is just like...
She's like doing things with her arms.
She's like on the keyboard and it's like...
And they're like, she's pretty good.
That's me right now.
These DDTs...
More like...
DD don'ts.
Why do people always spam at monkeys?
I'm not even reading it.
Too much...
Too mucho...
Mucho texto.
Sorry.
Anyway.
Because it's fun seeing your reaction.
I don't think so.
I don't think they do it.
Well, maybe they do it for my reaction.
Maybe they're just like...
The streamer noticed me.
But I just...
Mucho texto.
Do not read.
I have my limits.
Oh, we're only...
Okay, never mind.
I have my...
Even I have my limits.
Why are you not efficient, VTuber?
Efficiency?
Because I can't be peak and efficient.
Jaja!
Oh!
Wow!
Let's...
Unlock this.
And this.
Nice.
Holy moly!
Okay.
This one...
We'll upgrade next.
Which...
We'll get in no time.
As we said in off-guide.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Am I in trouble?
Nah, we're fine.
By accepting this money, you must play this game exactly the way I want, despite the fact that I'm perfectly capable of playing it myself.
We will be reaching 200 at this rate, Minto.
No!
Don't say that!
You're going to jinx it!
Supply drop.
You're going to die at 150.
Will I die this next round?
140?
Hiya!
I guess we'll see.
Oh, it's fast!
Uh-oh.
Am I in trouble?
Am I in trouble for real?
Uh-oh.
Ruh-roh.
No!
This is the second one!
Uh-oh.
That was close.
They stopped it!
Whoo!
We were almost in trouble there.
The bitrate is dying.
Oh no!
Does it actually die?
I didn't even think about that.
Maybe I should try again.
I think I get more of these first strike guys though.
I was thinking, because they're pretty, you know...
They're pretty good.
They're pretty good to have on hand.
You're very crunchy.
No!
I'm supposed to be goopy!
Like ectoplasm.
One ice monkey took you to a hundred.
And two ice monkeys are taking you above that.
Three ice monkeys!
Even further beyond!
Mortaring the loopy sections.
Okay, like here?
Sorry, that scared me so much.
Oh, here we go.
I think everything, every monkey we have is as upgraded as it possibly can be.
That's crazy.
This monkey... Where even is the monkey?
Where even is the monkey?
Yeah, we have a thousand lives even.
We're crazy.
DDT jump scare.
Okay.
We can't die now.
Not yet.
Oh, this one.
What does this do though?
Automatically triggers a powerful missile attack whenever MOAB class balloons spawn.
Ah, neat.
Minto, it was awesome meeting you on Off Guy.
Thanks Tiara!
I know what I'm looking at.
But I still choose to believe it's an ice monkey carry.
It is an ice monkey carry.
You're not choosing that.
That is the absolute truth of the matter.
Ta-da!
I hate having to circle over this though.
I wish it was an easy collect.
What else should I add now though?
What should I...
Oh, we can add one of these guys.
We can add probably a wizard monkey.
We can add both wizard monkeys.
We can add a necromancer.
And we can add a phoenix.
Kiwawa!
Let's go with Kiwawa now.
We'll add Kiwawa right here.
Oh wait, I didn't need that one.
Oh well.
Okay.
Now we'll upgrade.
Max efficiency.
Cha!
Oh my god, you're back!
Can't you be funny?
Like the person that always was begging for ice monkey?
Instead of an annoying spam.
Can't you have funny spam instead?
Oh, thanks mod.
Can I get a happy birthday from my Oshie?
Also, which hero monkey do you want to unlock next?
Echenane?
Echenane is my favorite.
I don't know that one.
Happy birthday people!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear people.
Happy birthday!
Yeah, why can't you guys entertain me instead of me entertaining you?
You guys are supposed to be the funny ones, huh?
Still cuts a tomato.
A tomato.
And look, while they're like everything is blowing... like this guy blows them back.
That's such a good setup.
I think this is the ideal setup.
No!
Don't copy and paste them.
I will have you timed out.
Thank you for watching.
And that's not a good... Oh, I don't think I pressed it.
That's not a good time-out.
Time-out of shame.
Do they have a wizard monkey?
I have a wizard monkey.
I'm gonna put a second wizard monkey.
Second wizard monkey will go... Wait, no, I want second wizard monkey to get the...
Here.
This is...
Necrom... Oh!
Okay, we're already necromancing.
Holy cow.
Okay, never mind.
Wall of fire right there as well.
Oh my god!
There they go!
I know we've spent a lot of money to get him, but he could just go immediately...
Like, you know?
Two men were robbing a liquor store.
And the first one says, this is whisky.
His partner shrugs and says, yeah, but not as whisky as robbing a...
This is whisky.
They would steal things with a 50k.
Hello, kitten.
Could you please answer the phone right now?
It's no master calling.
Hello, kitten.
It's pretty whisky that you're not answering right now.
But I would think that you would pick up the phone in about five seconds.
Or else.
I'm going to get very angry.
How's the bitrate, everybody?
Am I crunchy?
How's the bitrate?
Nice.
I'm putting you in the contraption.
Very crunchy.
Still strong, actually.
I didn't go to Off-Kai, so here's a regular streamer tax.
Thank you.
Very crunchy ectoplasm.
We're halfway there to full Phoenix.
Lord Phoenix.
I'm so sorry.
We should start calling Kiara that.
Lord Phoenix.
Look at, you see the DDTs like come up and stop.
It's crazy.
Wow.
Who said that level 150 was going to kill me?
You didn't die at 150.
Yeah.
I didn't.
Ooh, it's coming in hot.
I think that move is not so great.
It's better if like...
There's a lot of bloons everywhere.
She's got to clean up, you know.
Money?
Go for 200.
Oh shoot.
Oh, you guys, we're in trouble.
We're in trouble.
I just realized how far that got.
Yo, we were so in trouble.
But we were fine.
We were in trouble, but we're fine.
But I'm
not.
I'm done, I'm done.
Oh no.
I've done everything I can.
And done...
Hmm.
Oh no.
I already got all these guys.
Um...
We could get this guy.
Or a Bomb Blitz.
Blitz.
Would a bomb blitz be worth it?
I don't have so many... There's also this guy, but...
Oh, I have the Juggernaut!
I forgot!
Wait, isn't he really good?
I think I should get him though, right?
This guy will have stuff sending all over the place, right?
Oh, it's not that great?
Oh.
Not really?
I guess it just says only fortify lead boon.
It doesn't even... Oh god.
What else can I get?
We need a million XP.
Hmm... Pirate Monkey.
Oh wait.
What?
Why does it keep... Pirate Monkey.
Plane Monkey?
Do you have a middle path gatling gun?
I'm working on it.
Hmm... Maybe I can have him up here.
And firing down.
Or here, and firing down.
Maybe they can...
They can...
But I have a lot to go.
Until 60,000 to unlock that.
Middle path boat insta-kill ZOMGs.
Yeah, yeah.
I've been using that one.
I already have it.
The preemptive strike and stuff.
Mm-hmm.
What if our lasers touch?
Woo!
Oh, the bow!
Oh, bow.
Oh.
I keep showing right this show.
This one.
The Pirate Lord.
Oh, okay.
Let's go for it.
It's gonna take a while.
But we can...
We'll put him in here.
Sign him up.
And we're also trying to get to 50,000.
Oh my God!
Blalalalalalalalalala!
Oh, I...
50,000 please!
Please!
Why don't I have enough money yet?
No!
One pirate ship can eat three MOABs.
Dang!
Okay.
Good to know for...
For this to go down this way then.
I mean, I do like this one.
Really improve power and can shoot three grappling hooks at once.
Plundering extra cash from each MOAB.
Woo!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's hope that we can get the money.
Here we go.
I don't know what I just did.
But...
Oh, we have super crazy birds flying around now.
Oh, nice!
I think we're good.
And we should probably increase this as well.
So that we can get...
Pops by 100%.
For... yes.
Okay, nice.
So this is our next thing.
40,000.
Uh-oh.
Oh,
please!
Oh, wait.
It does another loop?
No way.
Oh,
just kidding.
Dang.
We were not...
We were not up to stuff.
Ripperoni, everybody.
All of our lives that we saved up.
That we accumulated.
Take my first time ever giving money to a streamer.
Thank you!
Weird ghost that for some reason uses real currency.
Hey.
The afterlife is just like real life.
I think.
GG, everybody.
That was an amazing run though.
That was the furthest I've ever been ever.
Oh.
Go away.
Cancel.
That was the furthest I've ever been ever.
So I'm pretty proud of ourselves.
Have 1,000 lives in a single...
We did that!
GG.
Pretty good for someone not even level 50.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
You can make it to 200 someday.
I believe.
I told you guys not to jinx it.
Gosh.
Well now I don't have to stand.
I can be big.
Big toe.
Big mean toe.
Bigger mean toe.
Yay!
Yippee.
Big toe.
Big mean toe.
I looked away for one minute, VTuber.
What did you do?
I didn't delete Ice Monkey.
I promise.
Clearly you needed more time.
More corn soup.
And helicopter.
Clearly.
Well guys, that was good.
GG.
I know that was one of the easier maps.
But that was a good taste of how crazy it can get.
Right?
Big mean toe.
Resort is classified as the easiest.
Yeah, it is pretty easy.
I think it is the easiest.
Like, I can agree with the classification.
Please stop talking about toes.
Sorry.
Dog strings!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Is this why Mean Toe has only nine toes?
And then I'm the tenth!
Nine toes and then a standing toe.
I'm standing tall.
The tenth toe.
You mean...
You mean toe?
Resort, Cubism and Logs.
Logs.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Cubism?
Oh, I was thinking of tree stump instead of logs.
Uh...
Cubism.
Oh, this one!
And lo...
Oh, I'm blocking logs.
Logs.
Logs looks pretty easy too.
But things when they like overlap a lot is...
Yeah, I can see it.
Expert.
Darkest Dungeon.
My sanctuary.
Hashtag ouch.
What does that mean?
Man.
Oh.
Oh, I can unlock some of these though.
It's kind of fun.
Off the coast.
High Finance.
Cornfield!
Just got my Bachelor's in Computer Engineering.
And moved into a new apartment a few days ago.
Let's go, Liam Stewart!
Congratulations!
Corn.
I love corn soup.
Actually, I just love corn.
I took Matara to Pepper Lunch for the first time.
And she was like, The corn was a good idea.
I was like, corn is always a good idea.
Corn is always...
the best.
Yeah, it is.
So...
I don't really have a schedule since I didn't expect to be home a little early.
But I'll be streaming tomorrow as well.
Don't know what yet.
We'll figure something out.
Um...
And...
Yeah.
I'm not quite sure what.
Same time tomorrow?
Same time, same place.
Same minty fresh channel.
Balloons same time tomorrow.
Imagine.
No.
I'm not gonna do balloons two days in a row.
That would be crazy talk.
I could...
No!
Don't even tempt me.
You temptress.
Stop being such a temptress.
Stop being so seductive right now.
Okay?
As an expert at this game, I'd like to offer you my recommendations.
The secret to winning is to buy monkeys and place them to pop balloons.
Riveting.
Advice.
I'll try that next time.
Thank you.
Sorry, can't help it.
Yeah.
Balloons.
Hope you feel better soon.
Thank you, I'm already feeling better.
Truly.
Like, I'm congested, but...
I even feel like...
Hold on, I'm gonna drink some of this green tea.
I hope I can taste it.
Yum yum yum yum.
I
actually couldn't taste it earlier, but now I can even a little.
Balloons is the cure!
I'm diseased and balloons is the cure, everybody!
Balloons...
So you'll let me play balloons tomorrow?
No, I'm not gonna play balloons tomorrow.
Don't worry, don't worry.
We found the cure.
I'm just gonna play more of it tonight.
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
And Johnny!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
Edward, thank you for 2 months!
There were so many...
I think notifications were really backed up, so there's a lot of donos that didn't show up.
So, DavidTitanium, thank you!
I got my Tetrio Sprint... That's what we'll do tomorrow!
We'll play Tetrio.
Actually, I thought about it for today, but I was like my brain's gonna be too smart... small.
Too smart?
No, too slow.
Tomorrow we'll play Tetrio.
So you can all thank DavidTitanium for that.
I got my Tetrio Sprint record down to 50 seconds.
Glad you're back.
I can't stop playing that game.
I haven't played Tetrio in a long time.
So, it'll be a great Zatsudan game, right?
What a great yapping game.
Teemo, thank you!
Cool things Mint does.
Be Mint.
Stream Be Mint.
Tweet Be Mint.
Did you know I've been a number for 2 months?
Yippee!
Thank you!
Glad to hear you're doing better, Minta.
I'll rest up some more so we can do more big brain bloons.
Thank you, Servo!
Thank you!
I found out my Waka vendor listed a Metal Gear Arcade machine.
Interested?
Yes.
I'm interested in the Metal Gear Arcade machine.
I'm interested.
Please give me their contact information.
Thank you!
Heard you held hands with a vampire.
What, me and Maria?
Yeah, we might have held hands.
Um...
Actually, I think I was the one who grabbed her head.
I think I was the one who grabbed her head.
I think I went in first.
Thanks for the vibe!
Thank you!
Eventual ghosts.
That sounds about right.
Hope you feel better.
Thank you so much!
So forward.
It's because, you know, Off-Kai gave me so much energy, so I felt like a little...
I was like a kind of... I felt...
Um... What's the word?
Corporeal.
When... Corporeal.
When I can manifest physically.
I was absorbing so much life energy that I was... Maybe...
That can't be why everybody got sick, right?
Corporeal.
First off, Kai was really fun for me too.
Thank you!
We're going!
I hope you... I hope...
Wait.
No.
I hope...
I'm glad you had fun.
Corporeal.
Golden Foxy, thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Golden Foxy!
Travis Thank you!
I think that's all of them that didn't make it through.
So thank you guys for the donuts as well.
Sorry that they got all blocked up by...
They got all blocked by the...
By the... By the gifted donuts.
But um... Yes.
I still see you.
I see you.
Thank you.
The gift wall remains strong.
Yes it does.
It's funny because I'll leave OBS open after I...
After I stream and eventually I'll hear a...
I miss you a bunch!
Thank you!
I miss you guys too but I'm back now.
At least until AX.
And then I'll be performing there.
Performing at the concert.
Not at AX.
You don't need an AX ticket to go...
To go watch.
But uh...
Um...
Oh!
Wait!
Maybe I should add toot-a-doo to my list shouldn't I?
My brain just had to upload in response to the toot-a-doo.
Sorry.
Maybe I should add one.
I'll think about it.
Anyway...
I should go, right?
I should go.
It is a cute sound and I love Steins Gate so...
Don't mess a fiction show up!
Why you guys have made to me?
Oh...
There's a story...
That only the maid cafe knows at Ofukai.
Um...
After...
The maid cafe closed...
They did a special... It was so funny.
They opened it especially...
It was for like Matara and I.
And um...
And I was uh...
I was like hanging out...
With some friends.
And Matara like called me.
And she's like, where are you?
You said you were gonna come to the maid cafe.
And I was like, ah!
I gotta drop some stuff off in my room and then I'll come back!
And um...
I went and did that.
And she was like, how long do you think it'll be?
And I was like, f-f-five minutes!
And so I ran to my room.
And I put my stuff away.
And then I ran to the maid cafe.
And um...
And...
When I opened up the door...
They were all lined up.
Even Matara!
She was lined up with the maids!
And they did the...
They welcomed me home.
And I was like...
It was...
It was a dream come true.
I was like...
Except Matara.
She kinda ruined it.
But I was like, oh my god, they're all lined up!
Oh my gosh!
So...
And something really silly...
I danced for the maids, even.
I danced a little bit.
Our group had the maid cafe time slot right before you were there.
Ah man!
Next time, maybe.
But uh...
I danced for the maids...
And...
Um...
I taught them how to do some otage.
They were so cute!
And...
They served me a sandwich.
But they said that it was really nasty.
And I was like, no, I'll eat it anyway.
And it was really nasty.
I couldn't finish it.
They were like, um...
Should we get you something else?
Ojo-sama?
But I'm not used to being called ojo-sama.
I was like, no, I'll eat it for you guys!
And it was...
It was so bad!
It was so gross!
But um...
Yeah...
I said something silly there that...
It's only the maids.
The maids, no.
Oopsie.
We had made...
Yeah!
I got to meet her!
She was so cute!
Her cosplay was so...
Oh my gosh, I can't believe there were mint guys players.
I can't believe I got to see them.
It was so awesome.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe it.
It's crazy.
Hmm...
What was wrong with the sandwich?
I don't know.
It was like a...
Gluten free option.
Or maybe...
Maybe their vegan option.
I'm not sure.
But there was like a...
A hummus and an avocado spread inside.
That just tasted so...
Awful.
Did you see the bunny?
I saw pictures of the bunny girl mint, but I never got to see her.
So sad.
I only got to see pictures.
Here's some singles for the maids.
I've never been to a maid cafe, but I assume you throw money at them.
Like you do at the club.
You don't do that.
But at my maid cafe, you can...
Throw the money at me!
Okay, get out.
Um...
But yeah.
Throws quarters.
Ow!
It's getting in my eye!
Oh god!
So awesome seeing mid-mid-sunny at the maid cafe.
It was so awesome seeing mid-mid-sunny at the maid cafe.
Thank you!
Fine!
What the hell?
Wait, what about me?
What about me, huh?
Thank you for the 10k!
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
The money.
Maids Sunny and Ruby were so cute.
Yeah!
They were so cute.
Here you go, pause.
Okay.
You guys...
You guys waited for this.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Gonna head out now.
Fun streaming.
Thank you!
I'm also gonna head out.
I'm gonna head out too because...
I should get some rest.
But tomorrow we'll play Tetrio together.
So we'll all be able to play games together!
How many people can be in a Tetrio room at once?
I don't know.
99?
100?
I'm not sure.
Let's do it.
Otomita!
Thank you guys for the warm welcome back!
I'm so happy to be home.
I'm so happy to be streaming.
And next time I go to Japan, I won't make the same mistake of getting the bad hotel.
And next time I go someplace, I'll stream.
Oh.
Oh!
I'll make sure of it.
Sorry for...
Sorry for being gone for so long.
And having nothing to show for it.
I'm so...
But...
Sorry.
That's all I can say.
I just feel so bad.
That I was gone and have nothing to show for it.
Except my cough.
Except my baby cough.
But yeah.
Otomita!
Thank you guys!
And enjoy the rest of your night and I'll see you tomorrow!
And...
Oh!
Hold on.
Since we have time.
We have time.
Wait.
Hold on.
Do I get an ad?
Oh.
No I won't.
Yeah.
Yeah Let me tell you something.
If there's something weird sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
I didn't cough as much as I thought I would this stream.
And I haven't even taken that much medicine today.
I think I'm feeling better!
I'm gonna test again tomorrow.
See how I'm... how I'm... how I'm progressing.
Feel good, feel good, feel good.
Freaky ghost maid!
Freaky ghost man!
Freaky man baby!
Ow!
What if my name wasn't made mint?
What if my name was freaky mint?
Let me tell you something.
Sleepin' makes me feel good!
I'm afraid of no sleep.
I'm afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed!
Freaky ghost bed!
Oh my bookmark is in there.
My face is a little crooked.
Don't worry about it.
There we go.
Bustin', bustin' makes me feel good!
Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good!
You know what?
If some artist is listening...
And if you're bored every one day...
If you ever wanna make me some...
Some new glasses that I can wear on stream...
That in one lens says like...
Freak...
And the other glasses say...
Oh wait!
How can I say Freak Phantom?
Maybe in both lenses.
And the other one says nothing.
The other one says why.
Freaky!
Master Minto!
And then I can say, do you like my glasses?
Feel good, freaks and fans.
Feel good.
Good night, freaks and fans.
Thank you.
See you tomorrow.
Bye bye.
Thank you.